the movie opens in the year
1974 and we are introduced to a man
named Marty Bronson who runs a Sunny
Vista Motel with his two children the
12-year-old daughter named Wendy is very
serious-minded and runs the front desk
efficiently while the 10-year-old son
named sker works as a porter you just
know sker is going to be a
disappointment every night Marty tells
them some bedtime stories to put them to
sleep despite being a good hotelier and
host Marty seems to be a bad businessman
as he faces serious financial problems
and almost goes bankrupt as a result he
is forced to sell the motel to Barry
Nottingham CEO and founder of Hotel
chain Nottingham hotels before
finalizing the deal Marty stipulates
that sker will take over the business
when he's older a condition that Barry
agrees to sker is going to screw that up
so bad the movie Fast Forward several
years ahead and Barry turns this small
family establishment into a luxury hotel
with the name Sunny Vista notingham
however sko pet is stuck as the hotel's
handworking repair man as Barry seems to
have forgotten his promise you're doing
the right thing Barry at a social event
Barry announces his plan to shut down
the existing hotel and build a larger
one by the name Sunny Vista Mega
notingham for this he appoints Kendall
Duncan as the future manager primarily
because Kendall is dating Barry's
daughter Violet after work skeer visits
his sister Wendy's home for his niece's
birthday it appears that the siblings
haven't seen each other in 4 years and
Wendy has gone through a divorce in the
interim sker greets his nephew and niece
Patrick and Bobby and presents the lad
with a gift filled with Hotel items
nothing for Patrick though shortly
afterward Wendy calls sker outside for a
private chat she shares that the school
at which she is the principal is closing
down so she has to travel to Arizona for
job interviews as a result of this she
requests that sker look after her
children for a few days sker initially
declines because he's useless but
eventually agrees when he learns that
Wendy's co- teer Jill will be taking the
day shift the next day while in the
hotel's kitchen sker talks with his best
friend Mickey who questions why he
didn't demand to lead the new hotel
Mickey also reminds sker that Kendall
might take everything away from him just
then sker receives a call from Jill
reminding him of his babysitting shift
that night sker who had almost forgotten
about it rushes home as Jill leaves sker
tucks the two kids into bed but they ask
for a bedtime story before he can leave
in response he looks through the
available story books but doesn't find
any of them to be good enough hence he
decides to create his own narrative in
his improvised tale he portrays himself
as surfix aot an underprivileged peasant
in a medieval Fantasy Realm who is
unfairly overlooked for promotion the
kingdom adors butt kiss a fictional
counterpart of Kendall other characters
in the story include Mickey as frier
Fred the children as stinky and smelly
and Jill as a mermaid teach teacher
throughout the story the kids make their
own additions such as the king giving
sir fixel lot a chance to prove himself
and a surprise rain of gumballs at the
end success and lots of balls sker is in
Paradise the following morning sker is
preparing breakfast for the children
when he receives a call from Barry's
assistant summoning him to fix Barry's
TV unable to leave the children alone he
takes them along to the hotel there he
comes across Violet and requests that
she look after the kids while he repairs
her father's TV following this he goes
upstairs where Barry is sitting in the
dark sker turns on the light only to be
bered by Barry who believes germs
multiply in the light while repairing
the television sker tries to strike up a
conversation about the new hotel and
Barry reveals a hidden theme rock and
roll sker points out that another hotel
already uses that theme hearing this
Barry calls in Kendall and reprimands
him at this moment he offers sker a
chance to prove himself if he can
suggest a better theme he'll hire him as
a manager of the new hotel replacing
Kendall I got a theme for you says sker
balls meanwhile Jill arrives at the
hotel to pick up Patrick and Bobby for
school later on sker is driving back
home when he is suddenly greeted with a
shower of gumballs raining down from
above it actually happened because of a
gumball truck crash on an overpass the
earlier bedtime story miraculously seems
to have come true but sker dismisses it
as a mere coincidence that night Jill
dro STS off the kids at sk's hotel room
for the night shift as she departs he
asks the kids if anything unusual
happened to them even showing them some
gumballs however the kids don't
understand what he's getting at stop
talking about balls Dad it's freaking
weird following this they proceed for
dinner and Mickey shows up with some
delicious hamburgers the kids who are
eating the hamburgers for the first time
find it really tasty however they decide
not to disclose this to their mom as she
won't allow them to eat junk food before
going to bed SK keer makes up a new
story this time centering around a
western theme in the narrative he
imagines himself as a cowboy who wants a
new horse to improve his fortunes he
asks a Native American chief for the
finest horse and out comes Ferrari a
bright red horse much to the Cowboy
surprise the chief gives him this
expensive horse for free sker wants to
end the story here but the kids are
unsatisfied prompting them all to add
more scenes continuing with the story
The Cowboy spots a damsel in distress
and saves her from sever criminals in
the aftermath the cowboy is about to be
rewarded with a kiss but an Angry Dwarf
kicks him David Lynch has entered the
chat with this the kids end the story
and go to sleep that very night sker
visits a Ferrari showroom and gazes at a
red car just then he is approached by a
Native American man sker is excited to
see him as he believes that his story is
actually coming true sker is in very
real danger of appearing racist here
however the man tricks him and steals
his wallet disheartened sker drives home
and on the way he spots Violet
surrounded by Paparazzi he steps in to
help the girl and scares away the
intrusive photographers just as in the
story Violet is about to reward him with
a kiss but an Angry Dwarf disrupts the
moment Violet then decides to leave and
that's when skeer notices her red
Ferrari he mistakenly thinks that it's
for him but she drives away leaving him
standing there this makes him realize
that only the children's additions to
the stories come true the next morning
morning Jill arrives at the hotel and
picks up the kids for school a few
moments after they leave Kendall
approaches sker and reminds him of the
maintenance work he also asks him to
stay away from Violet because whatever
sker is imagining between them will
never work out in response sker suggests
that he mind his tone because he's
thinking of keeping Kendall around once
he runs the new hotel soon the night
falls and Jill drops the kids off at the
hotel sker then leads them to the
rooftop of the hotel to relax amidst the
beautiful surroundings as they chat the
children ask if their father will ever
return sker doesn't have an answer to
this but he assures them that their
mother Jill and him will always be by
their side this makes the kids smile and
Jill leaves after wishing them a good
night when it's time for the Bedtime
Stories sker tries to pitch the kids on
the hotel theme contest but they're more
interested in Romance and action as a
result sker begins a story in which he
envisions himself as a daring Chariot
riding stunt man in ancient Greece after
performing some impressive stunts in the
Grand Arena he wins a date with the
fairest maiden in the land Bobby chimes
in adding a scene where the stuntman and
the Maiden go to a restaurant where the
girls are jealous of her beauty Patrick
further adds to the story describing how
the two characters take a Beachside walk
and come across an unconscious man
washed up on the shore the stunt man
kicks the man and lets loose a fish
stuck in his throat saving his life
following this it starts raining and the
two seek shelter in a cave which has
Abraham Lincoln in it hearing this sker
gets impatient as their story makes no
sense okay kids go back to the part
where I'm getting babes however the kids
ignore him and go to sleep the following
day sker is at the beach when he
receives a call from Violet he initially
believes that she's the fairest maiden
from the story but his assumption is
proven wrong as she's leaving for Vegas
at that moment he accidentally bumps
into Jill who is passing by the beach
after dropping the kids at school she
invites him to join her for lunch and
they head to restaurant just as in the
story they encounter a group of girls
who admire Jill's Beauty after this sker
and Jill go for a walk on the beach and
stumble upon an unconscious man sker
saves the man's life exactly as he did
in the story and a sudden rainstorm
prompts them to seek shelter under a
dock it's at this point that sker
realizes that Jill is the fairest maiden
and he falls in love with her however as
they're about to kiss he recalls the
Abraham Lincoln part of the story
sensing something odd might happen sker
duck and moments later a penny falls
through the dock this amuses Jill who
then walks away the scene fast forwards
to the next night where Mickey asks
about sker strategy for tomorrow's
business presentation sker explains that
it relies on today's bedtime story it
turns out to be sk's final night with
the children as Wendy will be returning
the next day in his last story sker
tells a space themed Tale in which his
character battles Kendall's character to
become the planet's leader since they're
in space Patrick wants sker to talk like
an alien with a translator beside him
after a fierce duel skater's character
emerges
Victorious mckm he yells he attempts to
conclude the story here deeming it a
perfect ending however the kids aren't
done yet and they decide to have sker
character incinerated by a fireball sker
panics and asks the kids to change that
ending but they fall asleep the next
morning Kendall visits Wendy's school
and discusses the unfortunate news with
Jill he reveals that their school is
closing down because it's the same
location where the Sunny Vista Mega
notingham is going to be built this
clearly upsets Jill but she can do
nothing about it later in the evening
sker drives to Barry's birthday party
where he'll be presenting his new theme
idea but before reaching there he stops
at a convenience store on the way and
buy some items that will help him from
Catching Fire upon arriving at Barry's
residence sker learns that the party is
Hawaiian themed and full of flames due
to this he opts to be extra careful
regarding the fire a short while later
sker eats an ice cream unaware that a
bee is in it as a consequence the bee
stings his tongue making it difficult
for him to speak afterwards the
presentation begins and Kendall goes
first to present his new Broadway theme
when it's Skeeter's turn he starts
speaking gibberish but thankfully Mickey
is there to translate after hearing both
presentations Barry appears to be moved
by sk's Heartfelt speech and ultimately
appoints him as the new manager later on
Kendall approaches sker and commends his
guts to tear down the school of his
niece and nephew for the hotel sker is
shocked to hear this and goes to talk to
Barry however the old man brushes him
off as everyone starts singing the
birthday song to him soon after the cake
arrives and as Barry blows out the
sparklers sker becomes paranoid about
fire prompting him to blast a fire
extinguisher at Barry's cake this
infuriates Barry who then fires him from
the hotel sker finally realizes that
this is what the children meant in the
story the following day SK goes to meet
Jill at the school in order to clarify
that he had no idea of the hotel's
location however she tells him not to
make any excuses and walks away later
sker is at his place with a sad face
when Wendy walks in she's also mad at
him not about her school closing but
because he taught her children that
there are no Happy Endings Wendy
encourages him not to lose the optimism
he's had since childhood after she
departs he realizes that he needs to do
something unexpected to change
everything in the next scene Barry
arrives at the zoning commissioner's
office with Jill trailing behind him and
pleading with him to reconsider his
decision meanwhile at the school kendle
is making preparations for the school's
demolition Barry enters the
Commissioner's Office only to discover
sker who has managed to convince the
commissioner to withhold permission for
the school's demolition this leaves
Barry seething with anger but skeer has
an alternative location with a beach
view for the new hotel this immediately
changes Barry's mood as he finds the
location even more appealing if only it
were that easy Jill is astounded that
sker simply fixed everything then the
two are about to kiss when Barry
intervenes saying that the demolition
starts in 13 minutes and he's unable to
reach Kendall sensing the urgency of the
situation the two of them steal a
motorcycle and Rush towards the school
after a wild motorcycle ride they reach
there just moments before the demolition
begins sker then announces that the
school will remain as is as the new
hotel's location has been changed this
brings joy to everyone except for
Kendall with everything back in its
rightful place sker and Jill finally
share a romantic kiss in the aftermath
sker marries Jill and opens a motel
named in honor of his father with
Kendall demoted to the motel staff on
the other hand Violet marries Mickey and
together they operate Barry's business
Empire subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching